voilà les français qui vont s'attaquer à
cette question de marioupol l'elysée a
fait savoir en fin de matinée qu
emmanuel macron pourrait donc bien
s'entretenir aujourd'hui par téléphone
avec vladimir poutine rendez vous a été
donné à 16h30 heure française hermès
charrier bonjour c'est un coup de fil
qu'on attend et qu'on annonce de l'ombre
en tout cas ici à paris ça va être la 9e
conversation téléphonique entre les deux
dirigeants c'est que c'est le principal
interlocuteur en tout cas ici en europe
celui qui continue discuter qui persiste
et signe a dialogué avec le président
russe aujourd'hui oui est d'autant plus
j'allais dire que le président américain
buy donne et sacs et vaches sur des
explications oui dis qu'effectivement
poutine doit quitter le pouvoir il ya
d'autant plus d'importance à ce que un
président européen tant qu en
l'occurrence le président macron
apprennent la place de celui qui fait
aussi discuté avec vladimir poutine
alors est-ce qu'il est convaincant est
ce qu'il ne l'est pas ça c'est une autre
chose mais à un moment donné il faut
arriver à faire passer d'autres messages
et il ya le message qu'on attend
évidemment quand on regarde marioupol
qui est un message de cessez-le-feu de
corridors humanitaires de voir comment
est ce que on arrête la population
civile
parce que forcément il ya des
bombardements que les russes
n'arrêteront pas les bombardements sur
mario paul de toute manière ils veulent
la ville donc ils vont là continuer à la
voir mais derrière je pense que pour un
président français qui a qui en plus est
en campagne qui en plus représente
l'europe il ya aussi toute la liste des
atrocités d'une guerre qui se profile
c'est à dire que plus on va continuer
plus on va se retrouver dans des zones
de conflit dur on va se retrouver avec
des ministres qui vont intervenir vous
parliez des tchétchènes qui sont en
train d'arriver mais on sait très bien
que les ukrainiens qui ne communique pas
beaucoup non plus sur ce qu'ils font on
des milices d'azor qui sont des
ministres est engagée en ce moment même
dans marioupol on parle d'exactions et
de crimes de guerre du côté russe mais
on sait que dans une guerre à un moment
donné quand on va regarder l'état réel
des choses il va s'en passer des deux
côtés c'est déjà dénoncée par le kremlin
jour de la sec la guerre est cruel
absolument a dit qu'il ya des tirs sur
les civils a indiqué les tirs sur des
soldats russes et tout ça évidemment
n'est pas à vérifier mais dans toutes
les guerres on s'est retrouvé dans ce
genre de circonstances donc la
diplomatie plus que jamais doit
s'atteler à ces problématiques là et le
président macron indiscutablement a
quand même une capacité de discussions
avec des mires poutine